have a video of a man calling his friend
to tell him that his girl is no longer
his girlfriend I actually haven't seen
this clip so yeah let's check out
Tiffany is no longer my
girlfriend thank god dude that woman was
the craziest person I've ever met in my
life oh hold up hold up hold up she's
actually we're engaged now she's my
fiance it's h she's no longer my
girlfriend she's my fiance what the hell
Mike I am so sorry that she's your
fiance oh my God so award I have seen
that clip I I actually have seen that
clip before that is really
awkward um I don't even know what to say
I think surely he should have spoke to
the people around him before making a
life-changing decision like proposing to
someone